what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic Wonder tonight is the Loki
season 2 finale and from what we've
heard it is going to drastically affect
the MCU obviously Loki season 2 is about
the Multiverse and the TVA being in
charge of the Multiverse and whether or
not they are pruning timelines to Simply
keep it at one sacred timeline one
Multiverse or if Loki is in charge and
he gets his way with the rest of his
friends they let the universe branch and
we get a Multiverse the only question is
is what happens after that what happens
when different universes start to breed
different variants of Kang they discover
time travel multiversal travel and want
to conquer the Multiverse themselves the
funny thing is is it's already happened
we've seen that happen in Ant-Man and
the WASP quantam Mania and the post
credit scene they showed us the Council
of kings and they showed us the
thousands and really infinite variants
of kings that exist right now who want
to take over the Multiverse now the
finale tonight we kind of know what's
actually going to happen because Marvel
Studios confirmed what we already
thought with their new trailer that they
released today they also released the
opening scene kind of half of it is
really the Marvel Studios logo and then
half of it is a little bit of what we're
going to see in the first let's say 30
seconds of the episode glad they're not
spoiling too much however they did
reveal a very important scene for the
finale today that we're going to break
down and then we'll go over our theories
for what is going to happen in the Loki
finale tonight also big reminder if you
want to enter our giveaway for a chance
to win a PS5 an Xbox series X some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items
all you have to do is subscribe to the
channel and leave a comment on our
videos the winner picks one item and we
pick one winner at the end of each month
now the opening scene that they showed
us today basically picks up immediately
right where the last episode leaves off
but it also picks up where episode 4
left off because remember time travel it
picks up right where Victor timley says
it's time to be brave and he heads down
the stairs to put on the suit to go out
where he would ultimately die however
right as he's going down Loki Time Slips
back in time to that exact moment we see
this here very briefly in this clip if
you look closely you can see Loki time
slip back to this
[Music]
moment can't get the LA chance get back
got it got
it
okay okay time to be
brave good
luck time to be
[Music]
brave now combine this scene with the
very first line in the trailer that
Marvel Studios released today for the
Loki season finale where Loki says what
could we have done differently this
confirms that Loki is basically going to
be in an Ora Boris right now not the
person but the actual symbol of the
snake eating its own tail he'll
basically be stuck in a Time loop with
the same event repeating itself but it's
intentional and he's not exactly stuck
Loki is going to continue to go back in
time until they figure out a way to
where Victor timley does not die to
where no one dies if they go out there
to fix the time Loom getting exposed to
temporal energy Loki now has the ability
to control his time slipping so what's
going to happen is that Loki is going to
tell everybody what happened what their
plan is currently doesn't work because
Loki has already lived through it he
knows that Victor timely gets
spaghettified he knows he dies so he's
going to tell them they have to change
something something is wrong what is
wrong what could we have done
differently then they're going to change
it then they're going to test it and
most likely fail again then Loki is
going to time slip back and say hey we
just tried this it didn't work we also
tried this the first time it didn't work
either what else do you got what could
we have done differently and then he's
going to do it again probably fail again
go back in the past and say all right
now we've tried these things it doesn't
work what else can we do and he will do
this as many times as he needs until
ultimately they figure out how to make
it work now we've also seen scenes of
Loki walking out on the bridge in the
temporal energy himself with no suiton
but keep in mind Loki is a God he is
different than anyone else at the TVA
because they are normal humans Loki is a
lot stronger and his body can probably
take the temporal energy better than
anybody else's even without a suit so
ultimately we believe that Loki is going
to be the one to go out to the temporal
Loom and fix it but of course that is
not all of the finale Marvel has
confirmed something huge he who remains
is going to return we can see so in this
scene right here it's very quick but we
can see Loki and Sylvie fighting and
Loki throws his sword at he who remains
and it is stopped now I have a theory on
who stops it we'll get into into that
but first big thank you to Highland
titles for sponsoring this video before
we leap back into the world of
superpowers I've got something truly
extraordinary for our Noble listeners
imagine that you yes you can become a
lord or lady for just $30 buying a plot
of land from Highland tile.com will
allow you to make use of a Scottish
tradition in which land owners are given
a courtesy title with more than 15,000
fstar reviews the Highland titles gift
pack is an incredibly popular gift and
the Highland titles app available from
the app and play stores is a new
addition that allows you to explore a 3D
replica of the land choose the location
of your plot and decorate it using
augmented reality embrace the Majesty as
every purchase helps to conserve the awe
inspiring heroic beauty of the Scottish
Wilderness you can soar into the world
of nobility My Friends by visiting
Highland ties.com and become a lord or
lady today use the discount code Cosmic
to receive 25% off your order that's
Highland ties.com and and use code
Cosmic so as we have been guessing and
theorizing he who remains is going to
return kind of what's really going to
happen is that Loki is going to time
slip back to the part from the Loki
season 1 finale where they go into the
Citadel and they meet he who remains and
from here we believe what we've been
theorizing this whole entire time is
going to play out he who remains is
going to reveal that this was all a part
of his plan him dying in the season
finale the timeline branching Loki time
slipping going back in time over and
over again to finally fix the time Loom
and even Victor timley is going to all
be a part of his plan in fact we know
Victor timley was a part of his plan we
learned that in episode three Miss
minutes told us that it was he who
remains his plans to give the TV guide
book to Victor timley so Victor timley
is a part of he who remains this plan
the only question now is Will Victor be
good or will he actually turn bad like
he who remains plans now in this
particular scene where Loki is is
throwing his sword at he who remains and
it gets stopped I believe that it's
probably stopped by he who remains and I
believe that time is going to get a
little muddy in the season finale
because I think the way he who remains
comes back to life is by Loki time
slipping to the past and changing it
changing it to where he who remains
doesn't actually die now I know time is
already a little bit confusing in the
MCU we learned an Avengers ingame that
changing the past does not change the
future however Loki has kind of
contradicted some time rules a little
bit they even contradicted the time
rules of the TVA but that's kind of
explained by time slipping even OB who
seems to know almost everything about
the TVA said it should be impossible yet
Loki has been doing it and I believe or
at least I should say I hope we do get
an explanation of why Loki has been time
slipping why it was possible and I still
believe that it is because Sylvie kicked
him through the door that he who remains
his temp pad opened when she took he who
remains his temp pad and opened the door
and kicked Loki through it I believe
that is what caused the time slipping
and I believe that was a part of he who
remains his plan if you rewatch The Loki
season 1 finale you can see that he who
remains takes off the temp pad off of
his wrist and pushes it to the very edge
of the desk right near Loki and Sylvie I
believe this was super intentional I
believe that he knew Sylvie was going to
take it I believe that he still knew
everything that was going to happen and
that he did indeed lie when he said he
didn't know what was going to come next
I believe he had a plan and probably did
see what was coming next and if he
didn't see it he still probably had a
plan and was still manipulating
everything all for Loki to come back in
this moment even after he died to bring
him back in a weird technical time Loop
way like I said it's probably going to
get a little bit muddy but he is going
to return in this episode Marvel Studios
has confirmed this the only question is
why why did he do everything that he did
in Loki season 1 in the Loki season 1
finale there are a ton of theories out
there but one that I really really like
is quite simple he was bored let me
explain this for a second in Loki season
1 in the finale we met a he who remains
who was King the Conqueror before in the
past he conquered everything he won the
multiversal war and then he ruled the
TVA and who knows how long he had done
that for but we know that at the end he
said he was older than he looks and he
was tired but what if in reality he was
actually bored bored of ruling a
peaceful TVA whether's really nothing to
do Nathaniel Richards AKA King the
Conqueror is in his heart at his core a
conqueror hence why the entire
multiversal war was started by the
variants of Nathaniel Richards it was
all the king variants who started the
multiversal war it wasn't king and some
other people it was the Kang variants so
what if he who remains had been he who
remains for too long and missed
conquering missed the feeling of being a
conqueror and wanted to essentially re
set everything well perhaps this was his
way of doing this and why did he need
Loki and Sylvie to do everything with
the TVA and the time Loom and Victor
timley well perhaps it was because of
the time Loom perhaps he needed the time
Loom to be able to manage all of these
other timelines to have the Multiverse
perhaps he needed all of this to happen
just so the time Loom could handle the
Multiverse and now that Loki is about to
fix it and he's about to return could he
return for good and begin conquering
again because we know the multiversal
war is what we are going going into in
Deadpool 3 in Kang Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars and tonight we're going to
find out why everything is happening so
let us know how excited you are and drop
your best theories in the comments down
below of how you think the finale is
going to end and why he who remains did
everything leave your comments down
below don't forget to like this video
And subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the upcoming Loki videos you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter as well
and as always thank you so much for
watching woof
woof